wish I could be
heart of that world
[Music]
hello everyone my name is Jacqueline
Coley and I'd like to welcome you all to
the first interview with the cast from
Disney's The Little Mermaid hello
everyone hello uh Hallie I have to start
with you because you are playing a
singing Ariel in Disney's The Little
Mermaid joined by an All-Star cast of
Emmy Tony Oscar winners Grammy winners
directed by Rob Marshall tell me what it
was like when he called you and told you
that that dream was coming true oh my
goodness well first of all I'm just so
grateful to be in the midst of these
wonderful human beings who during the
filming process was just amazing people
to be around it's a really a dream come
true Rob Marshall is the best when he
called me I didn't believe it he was
like Ariel this is how he told me
because of course when I answered the
phone he goes is this Ariel am I
speaking to Ariel and I'm like what so
what's weird is he said that to me did
you see of course
[Applause]
[Laughter]
but it was amazing yeah so it's just
weird the whole thing is weird and
amazing and yeah I I would see him
actually doing that as well because that
is I've interviewed him for Mary Poppins
and other things I mean this is the guy
that did Chicago this is Rob Marshall he
literally dances everything and Melissa
I do have to feel when you join the cast
it was probably Kindred Spirits because
I feel like everything Rob does is
theatrical but I do have to feel it was
also emotional like I as she was talking
I was listening to Holly tear up and I
was thinking she just does that I heard
just her singing voice like you had you
oh my god and I really had to it was the
first day and the first time that you
were just kind of marking the spot Rob
was like we just will you just sit and
sing a little bit of it so Melissa no
one knows when it comes on
and then I started crying day one so I'm
like I'm cool I cry a lot when people
think but it did and then they once they
played it like her recorded one through
the thing we were all crying and I
thought this is going to be difficult to
get through it's just it really is it
there's something so beautiful about it
and you've made it so your own and it
was every moment of of that in the in
the Rob Marshall magical world is uh
pretty dreamy I mean it really is
looking at this cast like I'm just happy
to be here like filling out this
loveliness on here I can't imagine what
it's going to look like to see you guys
in this new technology but Aquafina have
to ask you
um I feel like this was like a fan
campaign that came to life like legit
like you really wanted something by me
yeah
I don't know I mean like you know but
legitimately I know that you've made it
very well known how you feel about
Scuttle and you were very very vocal
about that early on but yeah talk about
about this because again I don't think
that was to that joke um the first
thought that most people would have but
I now I can't see anybody else oh okay I
take that as a truly take that as a
compliment yeah you made it your own
yeah I'm saying you've made it your own
yeah and I think there's something that
that obviously like about Scuttle that I
really identify with love Scuttle and
and to be a part of like this cast as
Scuttle is is um yes it's very it's very
intense was he your favorite character
at this movie we read that he was like
like literally like childhood like from
the first thing because most girls are
going for Ariel so again no I'm going
for Scuttle like I don't know but as I'm
watching a little mermaid growing up I
I'm like Scuttle is as everything
um yeah the uh definitely was one of my
favorite characters I loved buddy
hackett's performance in the original so
when when you know we got that call and
we got the aerial you know it was like
it was like uh like I really couldn't
believe I want you to just keep redoing
bunny Hackett rules
but you can do it
I will have to say both with you
Aquafina I think everyone's kind of part
of the Disney family but again it seems
like they're they're giving y'all Extra
Innings very quickly between shangchi
and then also with Seoul like you're
you're doing the Pixar moving on to this
but in this one you also bring some
Hamilton connections as well because you
get to play Sebastian with the man who
named his kid after the character that's
probably a nice little Hamilton reunion
I mean working with Lynn is always the
best because there's like a really solid
shorthand right now you know like he'll
bring a song and be like you do the
thing where yeah and then it's like yes
so then I'm gonna all right let's do it
um because it's been a lot of years now
of making silly rap songs together so
that's kind of the a little more than
silly you know just winning
what have you guys done together
it opened in New York
yeah
but Holly there's some incredible
collaborators with this entire sort of
thing I mean we have Alan Menke
returning to do the score and then add
more and all bringing Lynn with it
obviously Rob Marshall but just the
reality of how you guys are doing this
is something that they haven't really
talked about either so can you at least
like take us into the part of your world
a little bit like how was this
adaptation done like was it all voice
like how did you sort of blend the two
yeah well musically because I'm a
musician first so Alan Menken being in
the midst of him and just this beautiful
score of this film was like just amazing
for me getting to sing these songs that
we've all known since I was you know
little is crazy and then just kind of
getting to make Ariel mine in a way is
really a beautiful thing I was stunned
that they were able to take me half of
me and the rest CGI and like show the
real mean who I am and weaving into this
kind of just fantasy world of just
Beauty and adventure and it was
interesting when filming because half of
the time I mean Aquafina and David they
did their uh voice recordings uh before
I did my filming so when I heard yes
when I was acting yeah I would be acting
with the puppet so it would be me on a
blue screen on this huge stage by myself
a whole big camera crew and I would hear
them in my ears but like the little
puppeteers would be acting with me and
so your voices became so comforting to
me because you're my only friends I was
begging Rob to come back man I want to
just stand behind the puppy let me just
be yeah because I wanted to watch you
work some more yeah it was a really
beautiful experience but it was cool
because they became like my home in my
ears and then when Melissa came I was
like oh my God thank God it's a person
well Melissa I do have to say too
talking about Rob Marshall I mean he's
an award-winning Corey choreographer and
so much of what Ursula does is movement
I mean talk about him I mean Also let's
be honest everybody wants to sing you're
a big villain number I mean and to get
that sort of like I think both vocal
performance with the choreography and it
didn't mean he didn't make you do it as
you were performing it on live I know
yeah sure and that I mean it's my my
fantasy world in my head I'm a singer
and a dancer and I love I love being
around dancers I love that whole world
so much and so just getting to pretend
and immerse myself in that it's just so
funny because Dancers just dance like
when they're talking to you they're like
you know the thing when you do the thing
and everybody watching as I'm doing it
dancers can't not Mark your moves so I'm
looking out and John's doing the move
and Rob's doing the moves and sometimes
John just throws himself down on the
ground he said can you do a roll like
this and I'm like he's just rolling
around him again it's fantastic and to
be able to do that song and it's like
the like the broad that lives inside of
me I was like she she she's Ursula oh
like getting to to be her was just like
it was delicious you definitely like get
to live in your aunt main realness for
it like that is like so great but the
orchestra you also have the live
Orchestra both of you like that I think
adds a completely different depth to it
so talk about that part of it if you can
well this is her I mean not can you
imagine if I only make like bad puns
this is her world
I meant that literally that's a pun but
uh I you know this is such a new
territory and I was back in this tiny
room and nobody could see me in the
orchestra was was out and they were so
impressive it's just wild to watch that
many beautiful musicians just like do
their thing and Rob came and got me and
he was like I want you to come sing with
the orchestra I want you to stand in the
room and feel what that feels like and I
was like oh
we're gonna know you're gonna know and I
shouldn't do that and I don't want to
disrupt them and he's like if you you
may never feel it again you have to
experience ones and it it really was it
was one of the most magical things I've
ever gotten to do and he was he was
right as he always is that like the
feeling of those instruments and being
in that room I was just like this is
something I'll I will cherish forever
yeah meanwhile David and I in the booth
that came for uh well yeah
I want to give you this because as we
talk about the music I don't want you to
feel left out with Scuttle because he
does have a musical moment I think
hopefully if we get to see that sort of
Revisited but these guys have like Show
Stoppers so I want to ask you this
though what's your Disney show stopper
like because I do feel like from now on
at any time you go to a karaoke bar
they're gonna hand each one of you the
night to kind of like do the thing so
like Aquafina want to give you your hand
the mic moment okay okay my Disney show
stopper yes like okay all right this is
your Disney song okay okay okay karaoke
style Part of Your World does definitely
is a banger let's be honest
um and and then I also I really like um
The Colors Of The Wind yeah
okay besides the one that you have
if you could pick another to be like
Disney show stuff like a go-to karaoke
song for you again you're going to be
singing yours a lot so I'll give you
like an alternate to beat if you want
one I don't you know I'm not really
qualified to hit many of the
showstoppers I don't think but I'm a big
fan of like the like everybody wants to
be a cat like I like I like all the you
know apocryphal Disney movies so
Aristocats is actually my favorite yes
make sure I give you both the
opportunity before I I'm hoping that
this last part doesn't make us cry too
much and I want to get some Giggles in
first
yeah remember grandma
[Laughter]
I know I'm trying I'm basically trying
to Hype myself up so I don't start
crying because I'm gonna talk about
Beyonce and that's emotional moment
so what's your Disney song though if it
wasn't Poor Unfortunate Souls
um I would if I could I would love to do
a dead-on thing of Snow White when she's
like yeah
again I'm gonna go I kind of teased it a
bit because you now joined the Disney
Princess Pantheon and there's some very
illustrious people get to join you get
to join people like Anika Noni Rose you
get to join people like you know Vanessa
Williams sang a song for Disney's
Princess but I think all of us when we
got to see Beyonce as Nala and The Lion
King were like yeah
Disney princess too and you actually had
the benefit of maybe being able to text
someone after you got the part to be
like just so you know
I'm gonna be Ariel I'm just curious did
she give you an advice joining in the in
the Disney because she also has
experience with this entire process yeah
so she is just such an amazing genuine
human being and I remember when I first
got the role you know she's so proud of
me super excited but she's like all
about me just taking a stand for myself
and speaking up for myself and not being
afraid and I'm like I grew up in a big
family I'm the baby of the girls so I'm
always like shy and a bit timid
sometimes it's harder for me to speak up
so she's like no you can do this you go
in there you be strong and you know
she's just wonderful so I love that so
much and I do love it we had a great
interview with you at d23 where you
talked about the fact that you singing a
part of your world felt like a healing
moment for you like healing your inner
child I just want you to expand on that
because I thought that was such a
powerful way to put it that you wished
you'd been able to see this
representation back then yeah I mean
it's so important because Little Mermaid
was my favorite
there every time we'd go in the pool
We Just Pretend We're mermaids we'd swim
and you know when I first saw the script
and was going to audition I just thought
to myself you know there's no way I'm
gonna be cast because the version of me
that I have of Ariel is the one that we
all have of her when she's younger and
um you know her red hair her pale skin
I'm like that's Ariel it's not me so
getting to
take on this new role and kind of make
her mind in a way is really special and
seeing all of the beautiful black and
brown babies reactions just makes me cry
and SOB because I feel for my little
girl inside and um
it just makes me emotional but it's
really exciting and um yeah just a
blessing I don't know if that answer it
but that answers it and it also got the
misties going which is exactly see I
told you
David I definitely want to talk to you
specifically about Sebastian because
again he's he's the he's the director he
gets he gets the Bops in a lot of the
ways but I think you said that you know
despite the familiarity with Lynn this
was the hardest role you've had to do
which is saying a lot because you do
like a lot of verbal exercises in
Hamilton that I would think is really
hard I don't know how this would be
harder
I don't I don't I don't really sing like
that but also like there's just a
it just there's a and a weight to this
role either yeah this little crab
carries a lot of weight in my memory you
know he's such a he looms so large
um and so it's I just I did more work
for this than anything like a research
guy and I was I have I was in Jamaica
and in Trinidad and like talking to
calypsonians and like you know like just
like really trying to immerse myself in
like whoa
which island is Sebastian from like what
sort of training did he have where did
he go to school if he's like you know
British educated and came back what does
that mean like and how does that affect
his voice obviously because we're just
doing voices and stuff so but I don't
know it was so much fun because
um
that is a big part we don't like really
understand it as a big part of how how
human beings like interact like your
voice is so integral to who you are yeah
and so actually focusing all of my
energy just on that not having to worry
about okay what is my doing with my
hands like uh was was exciting and
really fun but then also all of a sudden
I was like oh no I've opened this this
Pandora's Box like this is an endless an
endless rabbit hole and uh
yeah so it was it was fun but it was a
lot it was a lot of work if you had to
choose between uh kiss the girl or or
under the sea which one was the one
where you worked the hardest between
those two songs probably under the sea
but only just because like I kept
wanting to do it again it's like there's
so many the the lyrics in both of those
songs are amazing but like the potential
options in under this year crazy and
then also I had to record under the sea
with Haley doing her like improvs along
with it which were just like shattering
my whole you know
why would anyone listen to this I don't
know why I just like take the headphones
off
again your voice is very intimidating we
saw the trailer everybody knew right
step in the best way possible in the
best way possible but there's another
presence that we didn't talk about
that's not here that is also
intimidating Javier I mean I mean I just
give me a quick if you can what's it
like to call that
um daddy and like the way you're smoking
respectfully I'm just talking about but
um yeah just tell us about that and you
can keep it how you want to but we're
going to have a different picture
no Javier was so amazing I had been a
fan of him for so long just like I have
of these beautiful souls and literally I
did not expect him to be like as kind as
he was I expected like a macho man like
you know and he is but he's so like a
teddy bear inside so it was really
amazing getting to know him and just
having him be this father figure it was
cool because I got to compare him to my
you know my real father it's very
overprotective and very King triton-like
so I just felt like I was playing off of
my own experience with my dad kind of
scary scenes I will say that I hope I
hope folks uh folks can can tune in on
that because that yeah yeah that's the
other story right quick I happen to be
there at the day that Javier was doing
his camera test and we had just finished
rehearsal and I don't know how y'all's
camera tests were but his were him
getting full dressed up in his full
regalia and then them telling him to
hold his breath and just dunking him
underwater and I'm like zooming a camera
in and out around
and I'm sitting there and I'm watching
him be like dipped in this tank of water
and I'm looking at the screen and the
camera's just like slowly panning around
his face and I turned around and I was
like I would watch this for three and a
half this is the most interesting thing
I've ever seen in my it was so like
amazing just the power in that man's
face it was like yeah I know what you
mean because before we would start first
of all any movie that lets me have
Javier as my brother I'm like yeah like
let's do more but just watching him and
he is he's so he leads with such
kindness but watching him there's a
reason who he is who he is before we
were even going I would find myself
being like hey stop staring at him
creepy because I was just like it's
fascinating yeah he's fascinating what
is he thinking he's he just kind of
exudes this
he's like so Tethered to the Earth but I
was doing the same thing where I really
had to be like cut it out yeah yeah it's
getting weird thank you all very much I
want to remind all of you that tickets
for Disney's The Little Mermaid are on
sale now